there's times where
I'll just feel numb
and then there's times where my anxiety
is so bad that
I'm just beside myself I don't want to
see anyone and
I feel like a recluse
um
and it's struggling to sleep the first
thing I think of when I wake up is
Nicole and Maine
um when I go to sleep it's Nicole and
rain I can't have pictures around my
home
because it's too painful I sleep with
rain
um
he's got like a duck tower that we
bought for him
um
and I sleep with that under my pillow
every night
he'll never
um you know go to school or get married
himself become an entrepreneur be a
dancer or anything what he wants an
astronaut a doctor he'd never be able to
do any of that and you know one of the
saddest things is Nicole never even got
to see rain
and that really bothers me because she
was so excited to see him I don't want
any other family going through what
myself and her dad and the rest of my
family are going through because it's it
I just feel like I'm in a Time Warp and
I just can't move on
um
and my anxiety through the roof I just
feel lost without them because Nicole
was my everything and anyone that knows
me my close friends and family know that
my Nicole was absolutely everything to
me black women are
failed in pregnancy
um and they're not taken seriously at
all
so
this is hard for me to even talk about
it that black black women or black
pregnant women are just not taken
seriously and there should be more done
for that
yeah Nicole was so full of life she
loved to dance since she could walk and
she loved helping others she's always
there for her friends
um and she was a good daughter I didn't
have any problems with Nicole at all
growing up
um and she was just my world
in terms of Nicole's social media it
just started to grow more obviously with
her dance and her traveling
um and then she started to do her
YouTube videos with her girls
um such as rhianne and I used to do some
crazy things
um and he just it was just so much fun
watching them doing it
um eventually it grew
her followers started to grow and I
didn't realize how many followers
um were engaging with Nicole until she
sadly passed away
um
but yeah she was just always loved the
social media
um
Nicole was very confident
a very confident person and she was just
never shy from such an early age she
also was the first one on the dance
floor and she just didn't care but she
doesn't get that from me by the way she
gets up from my mom because my mum was
just crazy like like she was I always
encouraged Nicole to do to do dance
because I always thought that at the end
of the day doesn't matter what you do as
long as you do something that you really
enjoy and you're passionate about and
she was always passionate about dancing
she used to travel the world
um and she also used to teach dance as
well
um but I'd say a more afrobeats dance
and she does a lot she used to do a lot
of commercial dancing and I used to love
going to watch her dance and in the
crowd I'd be sat there
um with other mothers and she could hear
my voice always me shouting
um so yeah I I just I was so proud such
a proud mom